yes but i think he had to try this idea
now he's got a if he can get the black
queen into the position then he's gonna
be doing very well here but how do you
get the black queen into the position
okay oh he's done it lovely maneuver
that one
lovely it looks lovely but
comes forwards yeah yeah actually maybe
and it does two squares from queening
how does he get the black queen in
prague shaking his head i think he
missed this one he's panicking under
five seconds again
time is so important at the moment he
has the move
okay he moves his queen okay he has a
deadly threat on the board the queen is
going to swoop down
canal
he has done
okay but the queen and rook said they're
deadly attackers so i mean it's looking
really really really bad for pragnanda
but
never say never until
they shake hands what they don't shake
hands these days but until the game is
over
i'm gonna say never ivanka unfortunately
i think this game is gone for prague
yeah it's two pawns and uh the white
king can never be attacked just by the
queen really now so